The joe rogan experience and this
extreme lack of empathy though the lack
of empathy towards anyone who doesn't
share your position.
This is very strange.
It's um,
it's very,
it's piss poor thinking and it's
everywhere
and in everyone wants to feel like not
being a part of one of the tribes is it
extremely lonely position and you get
called all the bad names because people
want you to be a part of their tribe and
people don't want to be called bad names
and they want to feel like they're are
any name group hug emotionally.
I totally got that.
Yeah.
Kind of sucks being homeless.
Well it's just politically homeless.
Yes.
It's just when you got a president
that's so polarizing and you have an
opposition to him that's so there,
there,
there's so much momentum in opposing him
and I think this is a giant wedge in
between these two sides.
And then you have that hat and that hat.
If that kid wasn't wearing that hat,
a guarantee and be like 20% less hate,
it would be.
It would be people would still get mad
at him because he was still like,
I've seen people say when a native elder
walks up to you and he's banging his
drums,
get the fuck out of the way.
I saw that.
Like,
come on,
you can't expect that you what?
You can't just beat your drum.
First of all,
he got right in the kid's face like
inches from the kid's face.
Pretty amazing.
The restraint this kid had to just smile
and the idea that you're going to judge
this kid millions and millions and
millions of people going over this right
now.
That kid woke up that morning,
he had no fucking idea.
He was a kid in a cult.
Okay?
He's in a Catholic cult school and he's
going to some weird thing,
some march for life where people are
trying to kill babies.
We've got to stop him from killing
babies,
right?
And he goes there and there's this black
Israelites calling them the faggots and
there's these all these people calling
them names.
And then all of a sudden this guy's
beating the drum in front of his face
and we're supposed to,
we're supposed to docsis kid now cause
he smirked.
[inaudible] that's a crazy,
an impossible lack of empathy.
It's impossible to defend like unless
you hate boys,
unless you hate all boys because boys
are dumb like 16 year old boys are
almost universally dumb.
They all,
they all grow up to be men.
Some of those men will be your best
friend.
So when those men will be amazing,
some of those men you be so happy to see
when you see him,
you'll give him a big hug.
Okay lets me write me.
I was a stupid fucking 16 year old and
I'm a man now and I try to be as nice as
I can to everybody.
I go way out of my way to be a kind
person.
That could be that kid too.
Like what you're doing is not good for
anybody.
It's not,
it's not good for society to take this
trend and run with it.
And this is,
well,
this is what people do now
we're coming home from a Christmas
extravaganza,
which I do with my buddies every year.
Right before Christmas,
we get a big card pile in and we'd go
Christmas shopping for our families.
And what have you coming home loaded?
I supposedly threw a burrito from taco
bell or something and hit the guard.
So there's four,
three or four of my buddies.
We get to my house,
we pig out on Shitty Taco bell food,
you know,
until everybody passes out.
And the next thing I know the cop lights
are,
are banging on the door.
Get out of here.
I'm,
I come to the door.
God,
Hey,
why?
You know,
after you've been drinking it,
he'd do a bunch of food.
You're fucking gone.
And uh,
so long story short,
they said,
well,
you're going to be arrested for assault
if you don't go down and say you're
sorry to this guy saw what?
A burrito.
Correct.
Right.
And by the end.
So if you charge a man with a salt,
because he throws a Burrito at you,
you should,
you should turn in your card.
But we were to tape,
it was not like throwing it at him.
It's not like I've barely with a
baseball right here.
I like chunked it to him to eat,
but he didn't see it coming and so it
like slapped him and fell down.
So they cuffed me,
they take me down to the guard house.
Yeah,
they put me in the back of a cop car.
Kofi cops.
These are real ones.
Oh really?
Yes.
He filed a report and a,
so this is how stupid it gets shaped by
then.
I'm so fricking loaded,
right.
And I get there and the Burrito is still
on the ground,
like it's evidence or some shit.
And they're telling me,
I gotta apologize to this guy and all I
can focus on is there's a perfectly good
fucking burrito round here.
I'm going to eat this burrito.
So I sit down and literally start eating
the Burrito God.
And you're like,
please just tell him you're sorry.
So you go back home and I'm like,
okay.
So I tell him,
I'm sorry,
I'm still eating a Burrito and they just
left me there like a mile from my house
at the guard shack.
You walked home with mild drunk,
a man named Mr John.
My wife and I own barber,
so people don't know.
We own these things called the shea
washing room shops.
We have one at state farm arena that one
of the Atlanta Hawks play.
We have our flagship store on age with
avenue.
Edgewood avenue was once an Auburn
Avenue.
Well wants to sinners of black Atlanta
in terms of commerce and retail and
money.
Atlanta life insurance company with the,
are you guys google?
Some of this stuff is big time shit.
You know,
this isn't the old narrative of we've
never had nothing cause that's not the
truth.
And Landon was a very rich city for
African Americans.
Still is on this street,
used to be owned by African Americans.
The storefronts in there,
their children.
After these people died off,
sold the buildings off and sold it for
cheap.
And I know this because a man named Mr
John who runs a grocery store,
they're stopped me one day.
He said,
you know Michael,
after we're gone and this neighborhood's
been gentrified and everything's
different,
they're going to come along and say that
white people stole this from us.
And he said,
that's not true.
He say the children or the people that
were here left and they never came back
because they didn't think what they
parents built was good enough.
Oh man,
to kill me because that not just black
people,
that's Americans period.
We have gotten to a point where we are
on appreciative,
we are entitled,
and we don't think what happened before
us was good enough.
So we don't treasure it.
We don't honor it.
We don't
reinvest in it.
That could be a farm in Milledgeville,
that could be a house in Adamsville,
but we have to do a better job of
appreciating ourselves,
appreciating our community and in
appreciate now greater community and you
have to reenter.
You have to reenter fi day.
You have to be a part of whatever
gentrification happens to make sure that
your stake is still there and that what
you care about from a morals and civil
perspective represented there.
I've known Bobby Lee for 20 plus years.
He's never put out a comedy special.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Bobby Lee almost got me killed at a
strip club in San Diego.
First Time I met him.
I already believe it be continue.
We were in our twenties and uh,
and uh,
uh,
I met bobby laid down there at the La
Jolla comedy store and then we went out
after the show,
this is probably like 90,
late 90 somewhere.
And we went out afterwards,
went out to the Strip club and there was
this Mexican gentleman with a tattoo on
his face in the 90s,
which is rare.
And he had long,
straight black hair.
Wow.
And he had a look in his eyes like,
he's killed people.
I'm a good,
I'm a,
I'm a good at sniffing out danger.
I'm like,
that's real danger.
And Bobby was hitting on,
his girl was trying to get a lap dance
from his girlfriend.
Got in Bobby's defense,
it's at a strip club,
but this girl was apparently his
girlfriend at a strip club and Bob and
uh,
the guy stood up,
you know,
and he stood up and he said something to
bobby and bobby comes over and he's
like,
fuck that guy.
And I looked at the guy,
looked at Bobby,
I'm getting out of here right now.
And he's like,
either I go,
you should come with me or you're going
to walk home.
I'm like,
fuck you.
I go,
I'm not getting killed for,
you know,
we all ran out into the car and I had a
Toyota super at the time and I got in my
car and bobby was like,
that guy ain't gonna do shit.
I'm like,
cat in the fucking car.
dude,
you don't understand danger.
You're going to get everyone killed.
It's guys like you.
Yeah.
He told me a story once about a,
he,
he's,
he's at mad TV.
They had a table read and uh,
he hadn't slept in a couple of days.
He'd just gotten back from Mexico.
He had a giant bowie knife,
like tucked into a shirt.
And it was fucked up on pills and he was
just sweating.
They been up for days and he's at the
table read.
And that was before he decided to clean
his act.
Yeah,
I was lucky enough to come across like,
well,
after those days,
uh,
and we,
they wrote,
they wrote a script to fuck with him.
They gave him the wrong script.
We'd like extra lines with a monologue
that took up like the whole page so that
he would have to remember it.
We know.
No,
he just had her read it and everyone's
like,
like jen cheap.
They tell everybody like,
don't worry about that part where he
thinks he's a bird.
And so bobby's like,
I'm a burden.
I'm supposed to.
And like the writer was coaching.
I'm just like,
do the wackiest bird boy.
And he's like,
God supposed to fly coach and I'm a
burden and he looks up and we're crying,
laughing,
and he see someone scream,
fuck you got any through the script
across the room.
And I remember just taking pictures of
yeah,
just to,
they just did it on his birthday or
something to mess though.
It was like the best prank.
Trump kept calling jeb bush low energy,
laying on the couch going,
that's fucking me.
He's talking about,
I'm laying on the couch and I hear about
somebody dying in an avalanche.
You know,
I watch it on t and I laugh because I
wouldn't have a fucking be dropped off
in a helicopter at the top of a mountain
to go snowboarding and then they die.
I'm laughing my balls off eating a bag
of chips.
Well,
the one person,
he's never called anybody anything is
Nancy Pelosi.
And people like,
why hasn't he come up with a nickname
for her yet?
Yeah.
You know,
cause you can't say content that's going
to cost him the election.
That will cost him about 2020.
Greg Fitzsimmons had a joke about that.
He's like,
it's countdown until trump,
that sick ankle dog face.
That's what I call Hillary,
adding the calorie count.
Uh,
what,
what kind of a nickname,
if you were going to help him,
like if he hired you like nick,
hello.
See,
I need a solid republican comic to help
me with my one liners.
What do you think?
Uh,
well I call her on my show for her.
The,
uh,
the leathery nippled.
Hmm.
That's too pretty good luck catching her
day like a lion,
ted.
Okay.
Yeah.
Fucking naughty.
Nancy.
What did he call Hillary?
Crooked Hillary.
Lying Ted.
How Bout Energy Jeb?
How about a yeast infection in heels?
No,
no,
no.
How about lying liberal?
Mm.
Lubbock stick.
Do you know that she's worth $100
million?
Yes,
I do.
The little people job.
She represents the working class.
You know,
she has fucking walls around our
matching.
Meanwhile,
people laying their own feces in San
Francisco.
Well,
that Laura loomer check the chick that,
uh,
handcuffed herself to twitter.
She hopped Nancy's fence and he started
setting up,
uh,
like uh Oh,
I grin camp nancy slot.
Did you see that?
What happened?
They kicked her out.
What was the result?
Illegal.
She's doing something illegal.
She's trespassing.
I would say Denat I'll be outside of
house gone.
This fence has a moral mm,
right.
Build that wall or don't I also like the
wall still,
but when we have a machine guns and
tanks and flame throwers,
like I took them,
you don't have to kill.
I'm serious about this.
You're going to laugh.
Okay.
Cause uh,
you don't have to.
But Sarah,
I love how we rule out lethal force as
far as protecting our board.
That's not even on the plate.
So I,
okay.
It's too many levels to pick somebody
off as they're climbing over,
but okay.
You something less lethal.
A supersoaker Filbert cat piss
or the,
okay.